Another
thing from their story that we have to
understand and prepare for today
is is allahel said and our brothers and
sisters go back to the story of loot.
Read it take lessons from it.
When the angels came to visit Lisatam
and he took them as guests
and he thought that they were humans,
they're guests
and he let them in and they came
running.
The the homosexuals
came running to the house of Loot when
they saw these men entering his home.
And can you imagine that
they see men entering his home? They run
to his house,
right? Look at their the level of their
desires. They have one another. That's
not enough. We want those guys going
there.
So they go to Lootam.
They knock on his door. Loot said
they're my guests.
If you guys weren't decency, they are
women. I have my daughters. This that.
What did they say?
What did they say to Loot? Have we not
forbidden you from having guests? It got
to that point
is calling them to take heat
is telling them to leave alone to
abandon in this this undecent action.
No. No. They said to go previously and
so we want you out of our city.
You and us can no longer remain in the
same land
and now loot has guests.
Knock on his door. Did not we prevent
you from having guests? They wanted loot
to be cut off from the rest of the city.
He cannot speak to people. He cannot
have people in his home.
So my dear brothers and sisters, it's
very important we understand that it
this doesn't stop with us them having
their beliefs and their actions.
Anyone who doesn't agree with them, they
do not want those individuals to be in
their company. They do not want to share
the same job with them, the same
neighborhood with them. Look, look at
what they reached. Have we not informed
you, you can't have guests? What's wrong
with having guests?
And those individuals did not realize
those were the same angels that would
destroy them. The same angels that would
destroy them.
Closed the door and said to them, "I
wish I could defend you. I wish I could
protect you." And they said, "Don't
worry. They will not reach us. We've
come to inform you about the
punishment." But the point of the story
my dear brothers and sisters and you can
read it in his totality. Look at the
level. Look at the level that they have
reached. Did we not prevent you from
having company? No one is to talk to
you. No one is to talk to you.
Another So those are some of the
benefits that we derive from the story
of N. And you can refer back to it in
the Quran. very important for us to
understand but not just to read those
stories as allahel mentioned those
stories are a reminder those stories are
a lesson
those stories are guidance for the
believers allahel mentions those stories
for a reason
as for their movement for us to
understand the danger of their movement
one of the things or from that which we
will mention
is that the number of foundations,
organizations,
committees,
government leadership is unprecedented.
This organization in their movement, the
amount of organizations,
the amount of committees,
the amount of foundations,
right? the amount of leaders,
politicians, unprecedented
never witnessed before that a movement
would have so much support.
And it's very alarming and it's very
alarming.
Not only that, but these individuals,
their organizations and their
committees, they actually come together
and create strategic plans.
And anyone that has any knowledge of
business,
strategic plans, three-year plans,
five-year plans
and what you have fortune 5 for us to
understand Fortune 500 companies, they
make strategic plans. Why do you make
strategic plans? Because you're looking
for growth.
Cuz you're looking for expansion.
Cuz you're looking for mass production.
because you're trying to avoid failure
because you're looking for a
sustainability
and many others. When those companies
make strategic plans, they're trying to
spread, they're trying to grow, they're
trying to expand,
they're trying to make sure that they're
sustainable, that no matter what
happens,
this company will last and survive.
The LGBT movement had strategic plans
for growth,
for lack of failure, to avoid failure,
right? They mention in one of their
articles, "Our 5-year strategic plan
builds on our existing strengths while
addressing the changing needs of the
LGBTQ plus communities." So they are
sitting down in England, in America, in
Canada. They're looking at their
strengths
and the challenges. So when they plan,
they look at the current affairs. What
are we doing, right? How many gays and
lesbians do we currently have? What do
we do to get to increase this number?
So the reason why we mention is this
because we want our brothers and sisters
to understand it's not that they're just
comfortable with their present numbers
and they're comfortable with their
present followers. No,
they're trying to see how can we grow,
how can we increase our numbers just
like a company like Amazon and others.
How can we make sure that we make if
this year we made a billion, next year
we want to make five billion.
So they're doing the same thing. They're
doing the same thing. They're sitting
and planning,
right? And monitoring. We're not We
don't have a new We don't have enough
new followers. We need more.
Which platform haven't we entered yet?
Where can we Where can we go next to
make sure we're sustainable? To make
sure nothing harms this movement. It's
for us as Muslims to realize it's a
battle.
Another thing to show you according and
these are articles online according to
the 2021 and this is two years ago the
US government census the data which is
collected the LGBTQ
plus community is the fastest growing
minority segment in the US with close to
1.4 4 trillion spending power.
1.4
trillion.
You know how much money that is
that goes into spreading promoting this
movement?
There's no minority that has this amount
of spilling power.
Right? That's a factor. That's another
addition.
Another aspect
entering because they realize something
entering into schools.
entering into the school curriculum.
That's a part of their strategic plan to
enter into a school into the school
curriculums to the point where and we'll
go back to a far mentioned by the
scholars out of the 50s something states
now you have seven or eight that have
made it mandatory
mandatory
for it to be included in the school
curriculum.
mandatory,
right? And then you have 32 of those
states, they don't have specific laws.
They haven't made it mandatory. It's
there, but it's not mandatory. Then you
have five that disagree and they
prohibit it.
And alhamdulillah, Florida is one of
them.
And then you have others that parents
can opt out.
What's meant by that?
What's meant by that is
if you live in those states that have
made it mandatory as a parent you do not
have a right to prevent your child from
studying it. As a parent you can your
children can be taken away from you if
you prevent your children from studying
it.
Your children can be taken away from
you. You no longer have the right as a
parent to protect your children from
this indecency.
No longer have the right. That's one of
the things that they have done. But we
wanted to mention a fad
of why they have mentioned schools or
why they have focused on schools.
That goes back to their strategic
planning. They realized
with
uh trial and error
that schools are one of the places once
they began to introduce their filth in
schools they saw a rapid increase in
their number of followers.
They saw a rapid increase in their
number of followers.
Right?
Islamically
this is a fact which is mentioned
amongst the scholars of Islam
the youth
and aiming at the youth an example of
that is mentioned in the hadith in
Muslim and it's mentioned this story
this hadith is mentioned in in the
chapter of patience
the lone hadith and many of us know it
where the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam said that there used to be a
king
and that king had a magician
and the magician became old.
So he said to the king, "I've become
old. Send me a young boy so I can teach
him my magic.
Send me a young boy so I can teach him
my magic." And remember the king brought
a boy and the boy every time he would go
to the king and be he found a monk and
the monk began to teach him. Remember at
the end of the story uh the he couldn't
the the king couldn't kill the monk awan
the king couldn't kill the boy until he
did what the boy told him to do. He dug
trenches and he lit fires and the people
jumped into the we know the story. The
point of that is that the scholars
mentioned
that the reason why the magician said to
send me a young boy is because children
are more receptive of knowledge than
older people. And this is mentioned by
in his explanation of he gives
paragraphs to this. He said
the the magician
requested for a young boy because the
young the younger the child is, the more
receptive and open-minded they are to
learning.
The more receptive and old and
open-minded they are to learning.
Right?
He said,
He said, "And because when you teach a
child, the knowledge will remain and
will not be forgotten." This is saying
this. This is a scholar of Islam saying
this, right?
He said and because of that
teaching young the youth is stronger and
more effective and has a greater impact
than teaching the adults than teaching
the adults. Right? Then he said
therefore he said there's he said
he said there's two tremendous benefits
of teaching them when they're young.
Right? The first
he said the first benefit a child can
remember
and memorize quicker than an adult.
Right?
Because the children, they don't have
the bus. They're not busy. They don't
have responsibilities. They don't have
obligations. So they're open-minded.
So they can memorize, they can remember,
right? And then
goes on to explain that he said he even
brings the statement.
He said like it is a a famous wise
statement and that is
teaching the youth is like engraving in
a rock.
It's like engraving in a rock. It
remains with them. They weren't
forgetting the point of that which and
then the last one he mentioned
He said the younger they are when they
learn something and they become
acquainted with it, it becomes their
nature.
It becomes their nature. So that benefit
or those benefits that shake Oami
mentioned is the same reason why they
have begun to focus on the schools on
the curriculum not just the schools the
curriculum the books and you may think
but what's the difference because if
they only focus on the school right
spreading it in the school but that
doesn't necessarily
that doesn't necessarily affect what's
going on at home.
We understand that. But if you focus on
the curriculum, you got them in school
and you also got them where? At home.
You got them in school and you got them
at home. And there was another article
by one of the foundations
which is in opposition,
one of the foundations which is in
opposition to the LGBT movement. They
mentioned the dangers
of this in school and they're giving
awareness to the parents. They said as a
parent you should understand
and I'm paraphrasing it. They said it's
not just in the classroom.
They said it's not just in the
classroom. This movement is a schoolwide
movement.
It's a schoolwide movement. So it's in
the corridors. It's in the lunchroom
as it's in the entrance to the school,
right? It's everywhere in the school.
So, they made a they made the school an
environment that promotes homosexuality,
not just it being taught in the
classroom. So, when your child is
playing in the gymnasium, flags
everywhere.
When the child enters into the school,
flags.
When the child is just walking through
the corridors, it's being promoted
pride.
Right? So they try to say you should
understand the dangers for your children
just entering into the school. Just by
entering in to the school.
Additionally,
how have they introduced this into the
school? Not only the textbooks and the
lights, the school library.
the school library.
So the books inside of the library and
children in general, they like to go to
the library to read, to enjoy, they do
group reading and the likes. So they put
it inside of the library, not only the
school library, the neighborhood
libraries,
right? So they supported the authors to
write books, the suggested reading lists
in the school library and in the
neighborhood library.
And subhan Allah, they have a suggested
reading list for all age groups 0 to 5.
And subhan Allah, what do you mean zero?
And this is actually in the public
school and the neighborhood suggested
summer reading list. It says 0 to 5 and
then it says 5 to 10 and then it says 10
to 15 and the likes. Suggested reading
lists. So they have bedtime stories for
that spread and promote homosexuality.
Bedtime stories,
right? Some of those books an example
and these are actually these titles that
we're going to mention are actually
taken from the suggested reading list
for children.
Boys meet boys.
That's one of the books talking about
and is no longer because previously
children were interested in books that
talk about camping, fishing, right?
Hiking, motorcycles. No, their books,
they make sure strategically to mention
the boy kissing another boy.
So what happened to the hiking, the
camping, the fishing? No, no, no. It's
strategic. So that one and you can look
for these books. Boy meets boy meets
boy. Another book, Queer Heroes. So now
Superman Batman is gay,
right?
So notice our children love cartoons.
Right. Children love cartoons. Queer
heroes. So now Superman and Batman are
gay. Captain Underpants.
Captain Underpants. By the way, my
brothers and sisters, it's not just that
the superhero is gay. No. In these
books, they mention about him looking at
the privates of another superhero or a
boy looking at the privates of another
boy. When was that in children's books?
That was never been choking towards
pride. Pride of the lion. So now lion
killed his gay.
Freak boy.
Two boys kissing. These are titles of
books.
She drives me crazy. A girl in love with
another girl. She drives me crazy.
Listening to my body. So a child
exploring his body and another child's
body. My dear brothers and sisters,
these are all taken from suggested
reading lists in school libraries and in
your local libraries. I took this from a
list suggested we had four pages in the
Newark Public Library and it's printed
online for your children to read.
Another thing
we mentioned about the issue of
informing parents or not informing
parents
with these different laws and in the
different states.
It is no longer mandatory for schools to
inform parents of the content in books.
In fact, pay attention and this state
taken from their websites. If a child
expresses that he or she is confused
about his or her gender, the school is
advised not to inform the parents.
Now you have Supreme Court cases.
You have Supreme Court cases that
parents are now
uh suing the board of education because
the board of education kept it from the
parent. Kept it from the parent. Another
article,
and these are all on their websites, as
an increasing number of elementary,
middle, and high school students in the
US have begun to identify as
transgender, school leaders have
struggled to figure out how to respond,
right? And whether to communicate about
their actions to parents.
I'm a parent. This is my child.
I'm a parent. This is my child. No. In
Maryland, for instance, three sets of
parents filed federal lawsuits in 2020
that challenge school guidelines
allowing students to express their
gendered identities at school. In some
situations, teachers and other school
staff are asked not to notify parents
that they are doing so. So, parents are
not notified.
In fact, you have teachers that have
been terminated who tried to secretly
inform the parents.
So you had some teachers that worked in
schools that felt it is the moral
obligation upon them to inform the
parent. So they contacted the parent.
The parent contacted the school. They
investigated. They found out which
teacher it was. They terminated the
teacher.
They terminated the teacher.
Likewise, another example of this
is the fact that they strategically try
their best to put leaders
or political leaders in certain
positions.
And that's why my dear brothers and
sisters,
when we deviate from the book of Allah
and the sun of our messenger sallallahu
alaihi wasallam, we fall into these type
of problems. Im Hassi
imbas
said an important statement.
He said
I im Hassan and Basari said a very wise
statement. Im Hass from the
he said when the Fitna is approaching
the scholars know about it.
When the fitna is approaching the
scholars know about they are aware of
it. they wore it
and when it's done its damage, everyone
knows about it. Once it's done its
damage, everyone knows about it. The
reason why we say that is because had
not our scholars informed us about
voting and taking part in politics and
the likes.
So all of better whisings who methin for
example voted for Barack Obama
the politician
that had the most support for the gays
and lesbians and LGBT was Barack Obama.
They were able to accomplish things
they've never in the history in the
history of their movement they were
never able to accomplish until he came
into office.
So now we understand the warning of our
scholars.